99 of what comes out of your butt
when you fart is completely odorless
it's the one percent
that causes the trouble primarily
hydrogen sulfide
hydrogen sulfide exists in a typical
fart at a maximum concentration of about
one part per million
and you might be thinking well the more
i can get into my farts the worse
they'll smell
yeah that's true but only to a point i
call it the fart limit
according to osha if your farts were 30
times
stronger they wouldn't even smell like
farts anymore they would smell
sweet sickeningly sweet but still and if
your farts were 100 times stronger
they would smell like nothing
anyone who got a direct whiff would
experience immediate olfactory paralysis
by the way it may not be medically
possible but in theory
a fart could literally be silent
but deadly